Joel might be a gruff, grizzled survivor on
"The Last of Us," but Bella Ramsey says that
Pedro Pascal's on-set behavior is wildly different.
Although it may seem like most video game-based
movies and television series seem to be destined
for failure from the moment they're first
conceived, there's no question that HBO's
"The Last of Us" has found a cheat code to
buck that trend.
And while there's plenty of possible reasons
for its success, many fans agree that Pedro
Pascal and Bella Ramsey's portrayals of tormented
survivor Joel and teenager Ellie are particularly
bright spots.
As with the original game, watching the unlikely
duo forge a close bond amid an anguish-filled,
post-apocalyptic world has served as the emotional
core of the series.
Pascal and Ramsey may have effective chemistry
as their characters in "The Last of Us," but
some viewers may be wondering about what their
real-world dynamic was like while they were
filming on set.
As it turns out, Ramsey has a lot to say about
Pascal's on-set behavior.
During an interview with Screen Rant, Bella
Ramsey explained that working with Pedro Pascal
was an incredibly fun experience from start
to finish.
She noted that what really stands out about
Pascal's personality is his overwhelming generosity.
Ramsey said,
"Working with Pedro was so fun.
He's hilarious.
He's probably one of the funniest people I've
ever met.
He's also incredibly generous.
That's the word that comes to mind when I
think of Pedro."
She continued,
"He's so generous with his words, with his
time, and with his actions.
He's just a super cool person to be around,
and he definitely made the set a fun place
to be."
Ramsey went on to fondly recall the numerous
conversations she had with Pascal while filming.
As it happens, the pair were able to bond
over their shared "Game of Thrones" experience.
Ramsey played the young Lady of Bear Island,
Lyanna Mormont, while Pascal played the scene-stealing
Oberyn Martell in the fantasy show.
Though the two characters never shared the
screen, it seems like they still had plenty
to talk about regarding their time on "Game
of Thrones."
Specifically, Pascal has one object he'd love
to bring from the fantasy world of Westeros
to "The Last of Us."
"I really loved my robe."
"I knew you were gonna say it.
That's why I said clothing.
I knew you were gonna say your robe."
"Well, because it looked f–king awesome."
As for filming their newest HBO show, it seems
that Pedro Pascal and Bella Ramsey relied
on each other heavily.
Pascal himself confirmed as much during an
interview with Entertainment Weekly, sharing
that their mutual confusion and sense of unease
during the extensive shoot led them to become
close friends in no time.
"We never stopped being scared or [were] convinced
that we were getting it right, but at least
we could rely on each other without question."
Pascal also mentions that his bond with Ramsey
came with a side effect, as their directors
sometimes had trouble getting through to them.
He recalled,
"There was so much time we got to spend together
on set that it was almost weird when we weren't
together, as far as shooting was concerned.
There was this fascinating thing that would
happen.
We were just kind of in our own bubble no
matter what."
"The Last of Us" may deal with some pretty
dark and depressing subject matter, but it
seems that Pedro Pascal and Bella Ramsey actually
spent a lot of their shared time on set trying
not to burst out laughing.
When asked about one of his fondest memories
from set by Augustman, Pascal responded:
"For me, it is those attacks of the giggles.
I start to think about what I hear being suppressed
in Bella's throat, like a fungal disease the
contagiousness of the laughter was brutal."
Ramsey echoed a similar answer, noting that
the duo were most prone to making each other
laugh while trying to film some of the most
gut-wrenching scenes in the show.
As the actress recalled, they would laugh
even…
"...while talking about our characters' dead
family members.
It would start as a little giggle and then
would really grow."
By all accounts, it seems that Pascal and
Ramsey got along swimmingly on set, and even
helped lighten the emotional load on each
other when filming got particularly intense.
That positive dynamic between the two lead
actors will hopefully continue whenever "The
Last of Us" Season 2 finally commences filming.